jumping into timeless for a second I
watched every episode I was a huge fan
of the show I couldn't believe the
twists and turns in real life they were
more dramatic than the show in terms of
whether or not it was going to go um can
you sort of talk about do you think that
timeless is definitely over or do you
think there's a chance down the road
that something could happen
um you know nothing's completely over
nothing ever really dies Steven you know
I don't know if timeless is completely
and totally gone forever
the I don't think there's going to be a
series I think that's I don't see anyone
you know we really tried to get someone
else to pick it up and I just didn't
don't think that's gonna happen but um
both there's always a possibility of
more of these TV movies I know the
actors are game to do it and you know
Sean and I have I can't say we've talked
about it a lot but we've you know
chatted back and forth and emails we
said we should you know one of these
days we should do it we should do try to
get another timeless TV movie going so
um you know I don't think it's I don't
we don't have any immediate plans for it
everyone is busy and working on all
their various projects but you know one
day it might happen that I've always
wondered that if why can't more shows
that are beloved by fans get like a
Saturday night movie of the week
you know um and obviously I know there's
a lot of contracts and all that has to
be worked out but it just seems like
it's just such an easy way to like see
these characters again it's like the two
hour movie right yeah yeah no it's um I
mean to answer your question it's
logistical II incredibly difficult I
mean even doing that last movie was a
lot because you know you're compiling a
you know you're the timeless or in a lot
of series are written just even the
writing are written by writers rips and
so you're trying to compile a writers
room not for 10 episodes or 12 episodes
or 20 episodes but for
one two hour movie two episodes in
effect and so trying to get your writers
even available to come back and do it
and then trying to get your actors
schedule is available and you know what
the reason we're able to amount you know
such production value on timeless is you
you build you know the huge sets but
then you like women a lot of them all
season but for a two-hour movie suddenly
you're building new things just for you
know that hour and you're still on your
TV budget so it I mean yes I would love
to do it I thought it turned out great
but like I had to say that was whose
episodes were probably the most
logistical challenging of any we had
done so I think the will is there I
think everyone in general behind the
scenes even the studio executives I find
even the guys and girls who cancelled
the shows they're always like they
always genuinely love the show and
they're rooting for it there's no evil
executive somewhere being like it's so
happy to cancel this it's like it's like
a painful call comes to them from
someone in some corporate you know tower
somewhere and tells them the numbers
don't add up and they're gonna have to
cancel it and they they always call you
like genuinely scrambling to try to find
a way to keep you alive and so everyone
wants you know it's like I think for all
these shows I'm sure the will is there
but the financials and the logistics are
just really really challenging I also
watched revolution clearly on the moon
dude thank you your your it's like you
and my mom you're like I don't know what
to say so I I mean listen I've watched
every episode but one of the things that
I have found is that and I really want
to get into this real quick is that um
so revolution high-concept show and you
guys had to do 20 episodes in the first
season I think you were aiming for 22
but it was 20 I I firmly believe that
these high concept shows on network TV
that are forced to do 20 episodes
essentially kill these shows because
they cannot it's really hard to write
the
things and I think something like
revolution if it was a 10 or 13 episode
show would have been a really kick-ass
10 or 13 episodes so what is it gonna
take for the network's to realize that
they cannot do 20 episodes a year of
high concept television because they
kill it in the first year yeah I would I
completely agree with you I feel like we
just couldn't sustain that story over 20
episodes I found that to be those two
years to be the hardest of my
professional life both in terms of
creatively trying to keep that ball in
the air in that format and and then on
top of that it's just even trying to
produce a show that ambitious to do 20
episodes of it was just so insane you
know I mean I think to answer your
question is I think they're getting it I
think this is I think 2020 is a way
different world than the 2012/2013 that
revolution was on the air I think you
know at that time you know networks
still had a model that were working for
them and worked on supernatural like we
know it never occurred to us to do less
episodes of something like supernatural
and frankly when we got picked up for 20
episodes of revolution or 22 it never
occurred to us to say you know oh we
should ask for less it just wasn't done
at that time often their word cable
shows obviously and there were you know
the beginning of streaming but but not
in the world you know not in the
neighborhood we were in which was you
know the broadcast network I think now I
think they're much better about you know
understanding that there needs to be you
know limited orders and that they have
to program all year round and show them
everything coming up in the fall so I
think things are changing for the better
but ya know I I agree that was a show
that I've said it in many other places
so you're completely right I'm like
that's a show that had no business being
on broadcast television and I'd you know
it was what it was and that's the way it
broke out you know and lesson learned
I mean I thought NBC you know they spent
money on that show I enjoyed in too many
episodes in season one but let's get in
yeah and by the way like my I had now
the same bosses on the boys that I had
on revolution in timeless I Jen Psaki
and Vernon Sanders who left NBC to run
Amazon and like content like that's what
I mean like like yes those two shows
revolution timeless didn't ultimately go
the distance but like they were they
loved the show
it was both of them and they fought so
hard for both of them and I'm just you
know I'm really happy to be you know
we're really happy to be back in
business